among women for example Chastity is a
big thing males really prefer Fidelity
and Chastity and female mates if a woman
gains a reputation as being unfaithful
or sexually promiscuous that's a really
hard reputation to do away with right
you can't show everybody how little sex
you're having exactly exactly
how do male and female friendships
differ
oh God how much time do you have
um okay so uh We're not gonna start with
the easy stuff
um
structurally they differ in terms of the
so males typically form these less
emotionally close looser but multi-male
friendship groups
females tend to form really emotionally
intense and close dyadic relationships
so female female relationships
that's one of the biggest ways that they
differ because it has all kinds of
implications for what happens when those
friendships break up female friendships
tend to be shorter lived and more
fragile than these more robust
multi-male friendship groups it has
implications for the acrimonious end
women share much more intimate details
with one another and this information
can be ammunition that friends can use
against each other when this friendship
breaks up they also spend so much time
together so when the Friendship does
break up there can be huge grief at that
um and I could go on and on talking for
about four hours about it but that's
those are some of the ways why would it
be adaptive for women to have
fewer friends with deeper connection
versus men having a broader friend group
yeah we don't know it's one of the it's
honestly we don't I'll probably say that
a ton
so we do have really great evidence from
non-human primate work
um Susan Perry's Lab at UCLA Joan silk
who is at ASU and that work suggests
that among non-human primate females so
capuchins baboons having just a few
close female friends can increase the
female's own longevity and the Health
and Longevity of her Offspring so it
does seem like there are strong links
between a female friendship and female
fitness
there are some indication that perhaps
in humans as well so uh Stacy rukus's
work perhaps in humans as well female
friendship is also Fitness enhancing
um our friends do a lot of good things
for us but why that would be different
among females versus males that's a
really great question and in humans yeah
we don't know
would it be a potential case that with
aloe parenting the Shared Parenting of
your child amongst usually family
members but then sometimes super close
friends as well the cost of choosing a
wrong friend to look after your child is
so great that the threshold for you to
call them a good friend needs to be
higher than for men if you're going to
go and try and take down some Mammoth
that you're almost certainly going to
fail at doing you don't mind to it is
that you go with right like you know if
one third of you are going to die over
the next week then cool like you can be
whoever you want but if you're going to
put your child into the hands of
somebody else that to me would suggest
okay well I need to make sure that I
have a greater threshold for friendship
than the the guy that just wants to
throw space at things and and talk [ __ ]
yeah so they're sort of um a greater
Confluence of benefits among men among
women maybe not so much so that's one of
the answers or possible answers is the
importance of allo parenting
um another one is this idea that
um our women
uh you know rebirth Offspring and
somehow we're closer to our friends
because our female friends hijack
this hormonal physiological mental
system
um that's probably not the case but
that's one explanation
um another one that might hold some
water the people like Tonya Reynolds and
um uh the late and great and Campbell
have been proponents of is this idea
that there's a long history in humans of
petrolocality which means that males
stay in their natal group and females
often leave the natal group and end up
in their male Partners group with a
bunch of co-wives potentially
and so if that's the case then females
are potentially going to be designed to
form kin-like relationships with people
who aren't kin whereas males have that
sort of buffer of uh what we call
lowercase R relatedness so if they help
each other they sort of help themselves
because they're genetically related it
boosts their Inclusive fitness for women
if they help the other women in their
social group maybe their co-wives
they're not related necessarily and so
they're not going to get that just boost
to Inclusive fitness maybe there's
something going on that predisposes
women to
form these kin-like relationships to
make other women
more invested in them and then maybe
more invested in helping them in their
offspring uh because stuff like
infanticide and even uh homicide is
attempted Between Women Within the Harem
of whatever guy they're with when it
comes to what men want for men that
they're friends with and what women want
from women that they're friends with how
do they differ
yeah so um my colleague Kayla Williams
who's a professor at Hamilton College
has this really great paper in evolution
and human behavior on sex differences
and friend preferences
um men seem to prefer the sort of
coalitional support social support
um women want more emotional support
um they also tend to want more time and
energy put into the relationship
um men also tend to prefer these sort of
what are sometimes called shoulder to
shoulder relationships so okay yeah
maybe we'll talk I don't care if we talk
I don't need to talk to you but I want
to do stuff together women it's more
face to face I need to hash out
everything that just happened because
that [ __ ] looked at me funny
did you see in Friends by Robin Dunbar
there was a study done on the angle that
men stand facing each other and the
women stand facing each other did you
see this no I read that book too I I
sent it to my parents because I'm in it
he was he was my old advisor he's the
coolest he is a legit Legend yes he was
on the show a couple of weeks ago so
nice in it he said that and this is so
fast I can't unsee this this is one of
those things that you can't unsee next
time that you go to a party look at the
angle that men are standing talking to
each other it's almost always going to
be slightly open so they're going to be
about 120 degrees was the average angle
that was found and the argument for this
that was put forward is that the only
real time that men would stand face to
face is if they were about to fight like
that's quite a confrontational this
front-on eye to eye thing and I notice
it in myself with my friends I notice it
in people when I go into parties and yet
you see girls and girls are totally
happy to be complete lately front on to
each other so yeah that's
confrontational undertone physical
confrontational undertone is super
interesting
that's it it reminds me so
if men are going to stand at an angle to
sort of
um defray the possible uh cue that oh oh
I'm gonna attack you
um there's some work that suggests that
maybe the reason that women share all of
these secrets and share these sort of
evaluative information I might tell you
who I really hate or how I really feel
about someone or a phenomenon
um is to say okay you have some ammo on
me I am a friend I'm a friendly you can
trust me and it does seem to work
um so if I share social information with
you particularly information that's
sensitive or even if I just
self-disclosed to you you're more likely
to trust me like me and feel close to me
um it's part of why we think that
venting works so well among women to
manipulate alliances right so venting
is different to just saying I really
don't like that girl over there because
of something that feels is that too
obviously sort of Machiavellian that
it's an outright takedown of somebody
else if it's couched in this sort of
frustrated agitated language that oh you
know I I I just need to tell you I got
to tell you about this thing and she's
such a [ __ ] and I I hate her shoes and
I hate her hair and she whatever
whatever is that what's what what's the
difference between venting and just
outright like being abusive to somebody
behind their back yeah um so I would say
that the a good example of venting is
like I'm just so frustrated Chris I
don't know what to do I mean
she's just canceled on me again and I
have a really hard time and I don't I
just don't know how to handle this
so
um what we think is going on is that
um it's not that venting is any less
Machiavellian although it might actually
help venters to not be conscious that
they're trying to harm a Target the
person they're venting about
um it's that compared to more overt
competitor derogation saying like oh she
canceled on me again versus
she sucks so hard she's so selfish I
hate her
um that allows you to harm the target
just as much so you harm their
reputation just as much in the eyes of
the person that you're talking to as if
you said she sucks and she's horrible
but unlike if you say she sucks and
she's horrible you don't look bad
your reputation is buffered how much
they like you is buffered
um it's really just this form of venting
that really makes them makes the person
you're talking to like the target less
but still like you just as much uh By
playing a agitated victim in one form or
another it doesn't make you look like
someone that's actually sly because
obviously one of the things
uh as someone that was a club promoter
for a long time I saw this that oh a big
Insight you learn about people that
often talk behind people's backs if you
pay attention is that you shouldn't
trust them to not talk behind your back
these are the they're not just doing it
for them they're doing it for everybody
for the most part but venting
circumvents that defense mechanism a
little bit because it makes us think oh
well you know as long as because I'm a
good person I'm not going to agitate
Jamie to the point where she's going to
say that I've canceled honor again
because I'm not the sort of person that
cancels so I guess the venting is a
little bit more surreptitious with the
way that it delivers it yeah so I think
there are two things going on there and
and one is exactly what you're saying
right so
um people think that venting of
inventors have much lower intention to
harm the targets and they think the
derogators have high intention to harm
the targets and as soon as you
manipulate that then you manipulate all
sorts of Downstream effects from venting
so if you think that I want to harm the
target say I that were actually secret
rivals or something then my venting
isn't going to be effective in making
you think the target sucks and my
venting isn't going to be effective in
making you think that I'm not aggressive
and I'm not manipulative
um another thing that's going on is that
so I subscribe to these these models of
friendship whereby people have sort of
friend rankings
um and so I might say all kinds of
negative awful things and break all
sorts of people's trust to my best
friend I'll tell her what everyone says
um but if I'm doing that to her she
might infer sort of as a cue if I'm
saying well Chris said this and I
shouldn't say it out loud but Chris said
this
she might think oh well Jamie values me
more than Jamie values Chris and that
could just sort of bolster where she
thinks I put her in my friend Network
and this is Kayla Williams and she
really is the top of my friend Network
and I really do tell her everything I
don't know why people don't assume that
fantastic
um when it comes to
getting other people to buy into you as
a friend
understanding that you're giving them
privileged information that in the wrong
hands would be ruinous
that seems like a smart
um a uh costly way to show that you are
of good faith like if you're going to
say I need to tell you about my chronic
flatulence it's been replacing me for a
long time I can't really talk to anybody
else about it in the wrong hands you
know that would be bad bad info uh
what are there any more nuances there
with regards to how people open up with
that privileged information does it
relate at all to venting in one way or
another
so I do think that venting shares and
comments and features with that sort of
self-disclosure right and to the extent
that venting does and can be a form of
self-disclosure like oh I just really
can't stand this person then maybe
venting
um enjoys some of the same functionality
as self-disclosure like making you think
I like you better or making you think
that I'm really trustworthy
um I would say too that the the ammo the
information so I mean ideally I don't
have chronic flatulence and it can't be
smelled right
um but something that's secret that is
really hard to assess that's the
reputational damage that's really really
intense and it might be
um so among women for example
um uh Chastity is a big thing males
really prefer Fidelity and Chastity and
female mates on average the set etc etc
um
if a woman gains a reputation as being
unfaithful or sexually promiscuous
that's a really hard reputation to do
away with right you can't show everybody
how little sex you're having
exactly exactly but if a guy gets a
reputation like oh you're a bum and you
have no job or you know you have no
income and he comes along with you know
a Rolex and a lamb uh my husband really
loves the effing Marcia logo which is
whatever he comes along into Murcielago
which means he probably has a small
penis but it also might mean that he has
a lot of money and so you can refute
that reputational attack pretty easily
um as with most of the reputational
attacks on men but a lot of the
dimensions that women are valued for
reputationally they're harder to refute
that's interesting so the currency that
women can manipulate
within a friendship group in terms of
what is most valued by other women and
specifically by men that are looking at
those women as potential Mates is
harder to falsify
yeah and is easier to manipulate because
for the guys it is more easy to show
he's weaker than me poorer than me
shorter than me whatever whatever it's
like look it's all it's relatively it's
all on display whereas yes this sort of
sociosexual elements of a woman's nature
are
hidden much more open to manipulation
absolutely
um many of the things that women value
one another for is Friends
trustworthiness and loyalty
those things are really difficult to
assess
um in fact everyone male female
Etc has an incentive to make everyone
else think that so I have an incentive
to make you all think that I'm loyal to
all of you and that you're all my best
friends because if I make you think that
I'm your best friend you're going to
Value me more take my side against more
other people give me more finite support
than you would over somebody that you
think is just your third best friend so
I remember reading something about the
common types of insults that are lodged
uh at women and at men and at women it
was accusations around Chastity and
um like sexual promiscuity uh men it was
questions around manhood dominance and
stuff like that so I'm guessing that
this just is completely in line with
what we've spoken about so far
absolutely
there's some really cool work by Ann
Campbell again she studied girl gangs
and you don't see that phenomenon in
women the way that you do in men even
throughout history Amazon's great myth
but women have not banded together the
way that men have to engage in
coalitional Warfare we just don't see
that
um although you know again
great great myth um
what we see instead is that there is
still even in these gangs this
reputation was integration this
aggression that's verbal but when we do
see women fight it's often over
accusations of being sexually
promiscuous so it's the reputational
denigration that actually leads to the
physical altercation interesting what
role does attractiveness play in terms
of impacting a woman's role within
friendship group's ability to make
friends fragility as she climbs up the
social hierarchy and stuff like that
yeah so
one of the things that we thought and
there are some data that that suggests
that attractive women actually evoke or
attract more aggression from other women
um and that might be the case because
the more attractive a woman is
particularly as a mating competitor you
know the more rivalrous or the the worse
a competitor she is for you if she's
really good looking she can get what she
wants better than you can get what you
want if you're another woman
um but what we're finding my grad
student Lori and Mary and I are really
breaking down uh what it is that makes
women threats computationally
um
and
what we're finding is maybe not that
surprising
um in light of some work by by people
like David Buss and Aaron sell it
suggests that for women attractiveness
is really important men value
attractiveness in women as a cue to
potential status and fertility and all
of these good things and attractive
women end up getting all sorts of
goodies people want to be their friends
people want to give them things they end
up getting bigger salaries than less
attractive women and so they're kind of
formidable they end up having
a lot of power that they could withhold
or a lot of goodies that they can
withhold from you
so it turns out that it that's actually
much more complicated when it comes to
attractiveness because people want to be
their friends even though they're also
potentially really dangerous rivals on
the mating Market if a woman's just
promiscuous then it's easy she doesn't
really possess any positive affordances
for me I can just say [ __ ] her and
aggress against her uh okay I was going
to ask why is it the case that guys like
to be around other guys that are
successful that have this sort of
trickle-down effect of of casting a
broad shadow of their resources and
their success what what's the difference
there
yeah so women end up facing this bind
that men don't
um guys love being around other
successful guys and they're even
actually pretty big fans of being
friends with guys that can out-compete
them on all sorts of things are disposed
to having friends that are further up
the hierarchy than you exactly exactly
you want them to be better than you at
stuff and it doesn't threaten you it
doesn't bother you that's great and even
when little boys are talking they'll say
like my dad's car is a rocket ship oh
well my dad's car is a bigger rocket
ship whereas little girls end up doing
very much sort of these weird strategic
gymnastics to not stand out and God
forbid never seem like they're striving
or being Superior because among girls
and women if you're the person that says
well mine's even better mine's even
bigger you're going to be excluded and
so women end up facing this bind of
having to compete to get what they want
but they can't necessarily lean on some
other women to do that because while
competing while striving they end up
being the kind of person that gets
kicked out of the Friendship group
why is it did that make sense yeah it
does I I'm trying to work out the
difference between men and women of why
the women seem to have a more zero-some
mentality when it comes to their
friendships than the men do
yeah so
I don't think we have a good explanation
we have a lot of good data that suggests
uh so Joyce bennington's incredible work
that men are more Cooperative with one
another they can handle more conflict
with one another they reconcile after
conflict more with one another than
women do
um
and with my with my grad student Crystal
Duarte we have some data that suggests
that it's not that women completely
disfavor competitiveness in their female
friends they can handle competitiveness
and female friends they just don't want
their female friends to be competitive
toward them
so if you're competitive toward your
arrival or even if you're competitive
toward the woman I don't like awesome
good for you kick that bitch's ass
but don't be competitive toward me
whereas guys are okay with that they can
handle that
um the best explanation that I think we
have really does come from Joyce
beninson's sort of
overview of the costs and benefits of
cooperating and competing in in primate
societies so males have this ability to
band together to guard the group in
Intergroup Warfare
females never did that they don't have
this pressure to do that and so for
males any one Ally might be simply more
valuable and so yeah we might hate each
other and maybe you know I want to kill
you but at the end of the day if my
group is bigger than this other group
even if I want to kill this other guy in
my group he has more benefits to me
alive than dead friend guarding and mate
guarding to me seemed like two very
similar uh Dynamics the fact that I
learned this from David BOS that mate
guarding if you have a partner that you
feel is starting to slip away from you
you move into a cost-inflicting strategy
where you try and bring down their make
value you do things like make sure that
you check their texts you make them feel
more insecure it can come up with things
like gaslighting with men it often
results in even domestic violence where
they can start to inflict physical costs
this is a manifestation of someone being
concerned that their partner is going to
go and leave them for someone else and
then I found out from you that there is
the exact same thing for friends and
that's friend guarding yeah yeah so
um friend guarding can look really
similar to make gardening it's just your
guarding a friend instead of a mate
um the sort of things that make a mate
poacher more
scary to you or going to be different
than the things that make a friend
poacher scary
um and so we started to investigate some
of that
um but I I think for me at least the
coolest difference that we're seeing is
that people are not that
are not just absolutely necessarily
predisposed to hate people who guard
them so if I guarded my friend there are
some instances in which my friend might
actually like that and use that as a cue
that I really value her and it's
probably the same case in romantic
relationships except much of the
research although
if you look at like 1950s women's
magazines it's different but much of the
research says that we just hate jealous
people we don't want our partners to be
jealous full stop and that's not
entirely true
um for our mates or for our friends and
I think that's really apparent among
friends if if I say to my best friend
like
you're spending a lot of time with this
other person and I I love our friendship
and I don't want to lose it
um that is a cue of how much I value my
friend and our friendship and my best
friend might love that and increase how
much she values me
I suppose
outward displays of jealousy are the
costly signals that we were talking
about before it's also opening up a
degree of vulnerability from you I guess
one of the sort of
common dynamics that people talk about
avoiding in relationships is coming
across too needy that coming across to
needy is something that is a bit of a
turn off for people and it can cause
many attachment styles to turn and run
so is there something similar when it
comes to friendships like what what's
the delicate balance between jealousy
too little the right amount and not
enough
yeah that's such a great question I I
was attacking
um about gratitude and the sort of the
way you have to calibrate gratitude you
can't give too big a present or too
small a present um recently and the I
think the issue is you just have to
hit the sweet spot so if I tell my
friend you know hang out with anyone
tell anyone anything I don't care who
you're spending your time with I don't
need you or need to talk to you
um that's the signal that I don't value
her as much as I should
um and yet if I tell her you know if you
leave me I will slit my wrists and die
like Frankie pentangeli um that's
probably not the best thing either
so what I think we have to do or are
these sort of
meta representations of okay where does
my best friend value me how much does
she value me okay she values me at a 10.
I need to do behaviors at around a 10
because if I do behaviors at an 11
too much pentangeli land bad if I do
them at a one she's gonna think I don't
love love her and she's gonna go to
somebody that does value her the way she
deserves to be valued so what we think
is that these things are about
calibration what we know is very little
I mean we really know very little here
I suppose this the the jealousy and the
concern must be one of the reasons why
people are sometimes
hesitant to I know that I was like this
I was an only child so I grew up not
really understanding how social still
don't sort of social groups and networks
and friendships and stuff work but I
always remember being very hesitant
about introducing a friend from one
friendship group to a friend from
another friendship group in case they
started liking each other more than each
of them individually liked me and then
they would become friends and then I
would I would be left out
yeah no people hate that women hate that
more than men but um I'm also an only
child so good for us uh look at us go
parents
um so uh I do think that people are
aware of that
um especially women
um so women report greater friendship
jealousy over the potential loss of a
best friend and a close friend
um although males promote uh report
potentially greater friendship jealousy
at the loss of an acquaintance again
maybe just because any one Ally is more
beneficial for me
um so I do think people are really
sensitive to this but our culture has
long said well jealousy is this horrible
Vice you're a bad person in fact even
researchers have said
um if you feel jealous it's related to
low self-esteem other personal deficits
um oh my favorite is that um if you feel
jealousy in a friendship it's because
you just are non-normally developing or
you haven't matured enough to realize
that no one relationship can fulfill all
your needs so even researchers are
[ __ ] on this emotion that people
have felt across cultures across eras
and probably even non-human animals feel
so what we can say there is we can ask
them do you feel jealous but we can say
they exhibit Behavior pretty consistent
with jealousy what like what animals are
proxy jealous
oh man so Jim Stewart uh horses do it so
female Mustangs in Spain will bite and
kick the friend poacher they sort of
have female best friends they'll do that
cows do it dolphins do it and Lions do
it it does seem to be a social animal
phenomenon
um so I think we actually if we knew to
look for it we'd probably see it in even
more social species and what you're
saying is
all of the researchers or many of the
researchers are [ __ ] on this emotion
which has to be adaptive it's so broadly
found in the animal kingdom and so
ubiquitous throughout all of humans like
it's here for a reason it has to be
signaling us this is something that you
need to pay attention to
yeah exactly if if it's so and solely
maladaptive selection would have gotten
rid of it but it's probably not so and
solely maladaptive rather it does some
benefit for us um probably in our view
pretty similar to us on jealousy
um it serves an Adaptive function or a
function tributary to reproductive
Fitness that says hey
don't lose this person that you value so
for friendship jealousy we sort of think
it's it's a combination of two things
I'm gonna feel more jealousy the more
that I value the friend that I stand to
lose so a best friend versus a rando
um and I'm gonna feel more jealousy the
more threat or replacement threat that
this other person stands to pose the
poacher so if the poacher is spending a
lot of time with my friend I might feel
some jealousy okay maybe my friend likes
them better
but if my friend definitely prefers me
to that person so if my friend has a
plus one to um
I'm trying to think of a concert I'd
actually want to go to that's really
hard right now a metric concert because
I'm I'm an aging hipster
um my friend has a plus one to a metric
concert and I can go
um and but their new friend also wants
to go well if my friend takes me then I
know she prefers me over her new friend
and even if she spends 40 hours with a
week with her new friend I'm not a
threatened because I know she prefers me
okay you looked at the differences
between interpretations of women's body
size and women's body shape what did you
learn
um so I mean I don't think this is going
to be shocking for any man who has
looked at women or for any woman who has
cared what she looks like but
um to the best of my knowledge it's the
first empirical study to show that fat
stigma is
sensitive not only to how big a woman's
body is but also where her fat is on her
body and so
um two women who are the same exact
height the same exact weight in the same
BMI
if a woman carries her fat in her gut
versus in her hips and thighs the woman
who carries her fat in her gut is going
to be stigmatized much more people have
much less favorable views of her
what do you mean when you say
stigmatized
uh so they feel less warm toward her
they probably be more likely to
discriminate against her in all sorts of
ways and we also have some data that we
haven't published yet about the
stereotypes they hold about her so they
have more negative beliefs about her
that she's lazier that she's less
attractive that she's less intelligent
okay why would it be the case that fat
in the gut versus fat in the hips would
have that effect yeah
so I mean Steve gullin
um and lasek have have
really exploded the idea that waist to
hip ratio which is um so if your waist
is small and your hips are big you can
think of um
a beautiful statue I'm trying not to say
Kim Kardashian but Kim Kardashian God
I can't believe I've said Kim Kardashian
on something scientific but whatever
it's fine
so small waste
big hips and thighs good for her
um
that probably doesn't signal fertility
it probably signals though future
reproductive value so the ability to
have more children in the future
um what do you mean what's the
difference between those two things
so fertility would be
um can I have kids right now so we often
think about fertility in relation to
ovulation which is even more immediate
that four to six day window of when sex
can lead to pregnancy
um but it's very likely more signal of
of Youth in particular this waist to hip
ratio and so and we do have some data
consistent with that people think that
the more fat goes in the gut or around
the waist the larger the waste gets the
older the target is particularly for
women
and so if we see that a woman has this
waist hip ratio she might be healthier
she might have
um potentially more useful genes for us
we I I don't know if I buy that
um but very likely a woman who has such
a waist to hip ratio is likely to be
younger and have higher future
reproductive value whereas a woman who
has fat in her gut
that's the fat that's typically related
to the things we associate with the
negative outcomes linked to obesity so
obesity doesn't cause these things
necessarily but things like type 2
diabetes and heart disease gut fat is
what's really related to that more than
just fat period which is awesome because
my ass is huge
the internet does know I remember
reading uh a bunch of a bunch of
different things that were showing
um tribe tribal women and this like
really insane sized bum and one of the
arguments that was put forward there is
that having a huge ass offsets the
weight of a child in front of the spine
during child childbearing that you
actually have a a different way that the
spine is loaded that may be able to make
it easier another one was that wider
hips create a physical cue of a broader
birth canal which maybe would reduce
complications during childbirth but I
did see
a study about maybe three months ago
that said there is no
correlation in fertility in like genuine
fertility between the waist to hip ratio
uh in women so I it's one of those
things where I'm like why do we like it
I'm trying to work out why men like it
and it does seem like it's the same as
whatever like good smooth skin or
something it's just a cue of
youthfulness that maybe we've managed to
kid ourselves into oh it's something to
do with the birth canal it's something
to do with the way that women can stand
up when they've got a child
yeah we can come up with a lot of really
silly or bad evolutionary takes and my
God we have as a field
um but that said uh I mean I think the
way that science should work is sort of
throw it all against the wall and test
it
um and for me at least that I would put
my stock in whatever elastic and gollin
have to say they're sort of the last
word on this stuff for me
um and so what we know is that across
cultures there does seem to be something
going on right this is the shape we find
most attractive so something is
happening it's happening across cultures
um it's happening largely across eras
um and whatever it is seems to be
something that attracts men to women
okay most of those things that attract
men to women are related to fertility
maybe fecundity youth that kind of thing
this is probably one of those things
um and and I sort of buy the idea that
it's it's this future reproductive
potential
um but it doesn't mean it's not you know
these other stereoplagia or and there is
something going on with the spine
um that makes women more and less
attractive during pregnancy
um I think David Lewis has some stuff on
that and how stiletto heels change the
shape of the spine and the bum so
okay these things are possible
um but if you wanted the the final
answer on it don't don't go to me go to
Lasik and Golan
um that's where I'd go how does body
size interpretations differ from women
to men
um do you mean that women view
themselves as bigger or if you would
have a woman if you have a woman that is
of a size and if you have a man that is
also oversized what are these sort of
interpretations about the guy if you
have a fat guy what do people think
about him because we we know what they
think about a woman
yeah so for women it's generally never
that favorable although I will say that
um so we had to create totally new
figures because for our stimuli because
no figures existed that increased you
know size to obesity that actually
varied shape and once you do allow shape
to vary
um people are more favorable of the
figure the female figure who is obese
but has that hourglass shape compared to
a figure who is overweight and has a the
her fat in her gut so their size
actually is trumped by shape
um for guys shape also matters
um although it's really much less clear
in our data
um what it seems to be is that um sort
of male typical gut fat
um
can relate to perceptions of being a
good dad so that that Dad bod phenomenon
and Mitch Brown has some stuff on this
hang on you're telling me that a guy
that has a dad bod gut is perceived as
being a better father than a guy that
doesn't have that
it's it's possible uh so Mitch Brown has
some stuff on that and and our data
would support that view
um this is the kind of thing where like
the effect is small in social psychology
we're often talking about small effects
and this effect is small but it's pretty
consistent uh people might think that
my guess is okay so you have one calorie
you can't spend it twice you can spend
it on mating effort or you can spend it
on parenting effort
um if you are a really hot dude you can
spend it on mating effort and do really
well if you're a dabbed bot dude not to
say that they're not hot plenty of
people loved Ben Affleck when he looked
like that I guess although that tattoo
is hideous but whatever
um so
if you have a more dad bod people might
assume that you're more likely to spend
your calorie on parenting effort because
you can't get as much out of it oh my
God okay so because because a guy who
has a dad bod presumably has more mating
opportunity doors closed to him
any potential energy that he does get in
is more likely to be spent on his child
and on his family because he he simply
has less options to do it in terms of
frittering away in the bedroom
I mean I I don't know if this is
something that Mitch Brown has already
done it's entirely possible but that's
the sort of mechanistic account the
perception that he's more likely to
spend his time and energy on parenting
and maybe less so unmating uh
that go with but of course that could
all be you know completely wrong and
that's that's half of what we do in
science is learn how wrong we are that
is absolutely hilarious okay so you
spoke about
um high heels on women there I want to
talk about the psychology of women's
wardrobes because I know that this is
something else that you looked at what
is going on with women's wardrobes why
do they dress the way that they do
I mean there is a huge answer to that
and we've studied a sliver of it and I
think I should say here that so much of
the stuff
um so women's clothing seems like the
sort of ephemeral silly little topic
um and even I agree with that
um although I love clothes and If Phoebe
Philo is listening send me everything
you got
um but
it's a really fascinating phenomenon if
you couch it and sort of situate it in
the world of these signals so feathers
on Birds
um
these physical signals that tell other
people about you and the dimension
that's different with humans is that we
get to pick and choose so peacock
doesn't really get to choose how long
and beautiful and Lush its tail is
um but for women we do get to pick and
choose these signals and they can mean a
lot
um and what we found is that
particularly when women are new to a
group they're going to meet other women
they're more likely to dress modestly so
as to not be excluded or attacked by
other women that they're meeting
why would it be the case that dressing
non-modestly would cause them to be
excluded or attacked
and um so Tracy valencoe has this
beautiful study where she had a
Confederate
um a young woman who was probably in
college and up in Canada with her and
this Confederate was dressed in one of
two ways when she went into a room to
talk to two female friends
um one way she's wearing khakis and a
blue crew neck t-shirt and she goes into
the room to talk to the two friends and
the two friends are very pleasant to her
she also has a ponytail
um and the other one her hair is all
like me she's wearing a low-cut pink
v-neck thing and a push-up bra she's
dressed very
um uh sort of racy
um and when that so it's the same woman
just dressed differently she goes into
that room
Tracy vianko has beautiful lists of what
happened to that can that woman when she
went into the room she got called a
[ __ ] she got death stares how did she
get called a [ __ ] bye
the two of the participants uh so two
female friends that were in there they
were chatting hang on they were friends
of the person that was coming in oh no
the two friends were friends with each
other they're two friends with each
other right and so this person comes
into the room and it's just like oh can
I take your surveys now
or you know um I'm trying to
to something really really vicious
beyond that they were being studied
they did they didn't know that they were
being studied for this uh yeah and they
still called her a [ __ ]
yeah right uh okay so this is the
classic you're doing a study and the bit
that this study is actually about is
upon your entry or exit from the study
which is the fake thing like the
questionnaire that we're getting you to
fill out has got [ __ ] all to do with
what we're actually asking you about
it's exactly the the old man dropped his
pencils how quickly do you walk down the
corridor at the end of the of the thing
like all of that [ __ ] yes but I think
Tracy's study would replicate yes
right okay so
what's going on there
yeah so I think women are using
especially this promiscuity cue or cues
to whether or not a woman is making
herself seem sexually available as to
the benefits and costs that this woman
stands to pose so if another woman is in
the vicinity and she is making her uh
reproductive resources really widely
available by being promiscuous or just
advertising that she is open for sex
other women don't like that other women
view that as potentially threatening
um which there are multiple reasons for
that we can go into if you'd like but
women don't like it they even women who
themselves are promiscuous don't want
other promiscuous women as friends
um
what are the reasons for it why is it
that women have got this concern yeah so
the predominant reason in the literature
um tends to be about mating competition
so she's gonna take the guy that I want
um or she's going to take the guy that I
have and if she takes the guy that I
have well and I'm a woman
um well you know I've invested a lot
I've aged during the time that I've
invested so perhaps I have less power on
the mating market and if I have a child
that child really benefits from the
man's resources which he's now going to
potentially divert to her
um so those are the predominant
explanations I think what's missing from
that is this notion that um if another
woman makes so you think of it like a
market like um
uh sort of uh biological market and if
men are trading resources for
Reproductive access and a CIS het mating
Market
um if women
are voluntarily accepting fewer
resources
for access to their reproduction
um
and another woman's doing that it lowers
the value of my resource on the market
too
and so I think that's an explanation
that we need to look at so if she's
pardon the crude language if she's
giving it away for free
it lowers the price that I can charge
for it I got destroyed on Instagram for
putting up a video of me speaking to
Jeffrey Miller explaining the game
theory of [ __ ] shaming so I put it up
and it was exactly this right it's like
that [ __ ] shaming is a price enforcement
mechanism it ensures that no one woman
is able to drop the price of sex for all
women below a price that most women want
to pay and by [ __ ] shaming what you do
is you enforce more restrictive sexual
norms and a sexual price that raises
that backup
a number of the number of people that
were particularly unhappy with me it
mostly came from women perhaps
unsurprisingly uh have you seen
any data that suggests that most [ __ ]
shaming comes from women rather than men
um you know I don't know of anything
that suggests obviously there's all of
the stuff on the double standard but
that's about the targets being women
rather than men I don't know of anything
that women themselves are more likely to
do it
um I can't say anecdotally you know
somebody that also studies this stuff
um
I have gotten uh so
there are people
from the sort of even more feminist wing
of my life that would say that I'm doing
a disservice to women by talking about
the what I would consider the beautiful
strategic nature of their aggression
um and then other people say yeah look
they are evil manipulative [ __ ] so I
get it I do get it and I think we could
talk about this stuff in a way that
really honors how beautiful and
strategic women can be it's it's no
surprise that men can do this yeah we
should also elucidate the gorgeous
viciousness that women can visit on each
other and I I don't know why we think of
that as somehow worse well it triggers a
lot of people right there is a a real
sort of Elegance to the the samurai
blade that uh women's intersexual
competition wields and but it also quite
rightly to the people who uh don't want
mask off female manipulation to be shown
anywhere that women are sort of to be
seen as this protected class that never
do anything wrong it's it's bad to them
and then to the side that want to say
see they are the manipulative [ __ ] that
we've said that they were all along they
they also kind of don't want to see it
and they use it as a cudjoe to beat the
other people so the the comments on that
postcard
uh pretty spicy it hasn't gone up on
YouTube yet but I'm looking forward to
seeing what happens when that that goes
on as well oh God I'm not that's pretty
awful pretty it's pretty don't worry
about it um how do you know
that the
intersexual
changes that women make with their
wardrobe aren't just outfit choices that
women are dressing for men with like how
do you control for the the male
influence on on outfits
I mean the the really simple answer is
you do an experiment and you tell women
you're going to hang out with only other
women tonight
um and then you let them draw an outfit
that they would wear
um and you measure the number of squares
where skin is showing versus not or um
for real we did that um you could also
do uh so there's this paper doll set
that um uh Stephanie northover put
together and it's uh women in different
outfits sort of um Illustrated and a
different set of people said this outfit
is modest this outfit is really not
modest and you just say hey women you're
gonna hang out with only other women
what outfit do you want to wear
um and then we see how modest that
outfit is or on average what what we
can't do because it in an experiment or
probably also in real life it it's
really a weird setup is say okay you're
only going to hang out with other women
you're going to hang out in a mixed sex
group or you're gonna only hang out with
other men you're gonna be the only lady
there that gets into sort of a promising
young woman territory at the end of the
movie and nobody wants to study that or
maybe some people do but not me yes so
is there any is there any data to
suggest that men see women who are
showing more flesh as more sexually
available my point being here that you
could have a case of cross-sex mind
reading gone bad I don't think that that
is the case I think that
I see a girl walking down the street
who's got a habit on or whatever and I
consider her to be someone who is less
sexually promiscuous than someone that's
wearing a bikini uh but it may be it
could have been the case that women were
seeing other women that wear fewer
clothes as being more sexually
promiscuous and trying to attract more
mates but men wouldn't have paid that
much attention to it yeah I mean you
know that's one of the things that there
must be a study on that
um although I've said that multiple
times and went into the literature and
it turns out there's not
um I don't think that that is a
particular instance of cross-sex mind
reading gone wrong
um I will say so I don't know if you've
had Candace Blake on yet but Mike coming
on toward the end of this year I'm
excited yes she's amazing
um and she has some really cool work on
the sort of benefits of beautification
uh women's self-beautification when it's
not just for men so it's entirely
possible
um but it probably here we're gonna
start getting into the real nuances of
things so am I putting on a push-up bra
just for me
um maybe less so than I'm you know
putting on
um my particular favorite shirt even if
it looks skimpy just for me
um but Candace Candace will answer that
far better than I can I think that women
get it right when they read other
women's outfits right and I guess there
is a a balancing act going on here that
women are playing especially if they're
a woman that's trying to find a mate
because they want to give off cues of
sexual availability of reproductive
Fitness of being attractive to men but
if they overcook that they're going to
end up being completely ostracized by
the or more likely to be ostracized and
treated aggressively by women that are
in their friend group so there is this
sort of
game balance that's being played here
absolutely and so what I again I I think
that this is just evidence of women
being really strategic and flexible
women know what other women view as not
okay clothing
and women flexibly decide what to wear
based on the context and how at risk for
other women's aggression they are so if
I'm more attractive I'm more at risk for
other women's aggression potentially and
I am especially likely to wear modest
clothing when I'm new to a group I'm
just meeting people I don't have friends
I'm at greatest risk for incurring
aggression
um and additionally when I'm new to the
group versus not if I'm about to go meet
my friends I can wear whatever I want to
meet my friends I'm not at high risk for
aggression and so women understand this
about other women's Minds it's not some
massive calculation it's something that
we do quickly and simply but it's also
beautiful strategic thinking and uh yeah
I I think that that's lovely so it seems
to me that there is a line to be drawn
between these strategies that women
deploy when it comes to their wardrobe
choice and their opinions on abortion
and on being pro-choice or pro-life uh
their intra-sexual competition and you
did an interesting article that I read
about attitudes to abortion as a mating
strategy rather than being about
sanctity of Life do you take us through
that yeah so um this is with Marty
Hazelton at UCLA who is just a killer
scientist
um and a lot of it rehashes work from
her student David pinsoff who's badass
as hell created Cards Against Humanity
um and uh folks like Jason Whedon and
Rob Cruz band so credit where credit is
due but the the gist of it is that
people naturally vary in their sexual
strategies some people are really
committed they want to get married early
to one partner have a lot of kids invest
really heavily in those kids
and then there are some other people on
the other end of the same Spectrum who
prefer to sort of play the field for
longer and have more sex with more
different people
so there's this natural variation
and what's pretty interesting is that
the people who are committed sexual
strategists are and can understandably
be threatened by the uncommitted
strategists so if I'm a woman who got
married very early I'm raising four kids
I've sort of
um can't economically support myself my
partner is the breadwinner and he leaves
me for this woman who is advertising her
Wares
um I'm I'm in a pretty big hole that
that's pretty awful likewise if I'm a
man who's investing so much in my kids
but I've been cuckolded and they're not
my kids because this a promiscuous
gentleman came over and they're his kids
well that's not great either
so these committed strategists benefit
by preventing the less committed
strategist from pursuing their preferred
strategy by being uncommitted having
more sex with more different people if
they can decrease the atmosphere of
casual sex or low-cost casual sex then
they benefit
so did that make sense so far yeah of
course okay awesome Okay so
once you realize that
then you start to you you can
problematize I love when people say
these words you can problematize things
like okay so why do people oppose
abortion
um It's actually kind of a really
fascinating question to think about why
I should give any shits whatsoever about
somebody who's not related to me who
might not even be in my state what
they're doing with their fetus or their
family
it doesn't affect my fitness so why
should I care
and then I think the explanation is that
people vary on fit on sexual strategies
and if they're pursuing casual sex or
other people in my environment even if
I'm not related to them etc etc are
freely pursuing casual sex and I'm a
committed strategist that can screw me
up
and so committed sexual strategists
stand to benefit by decreasing the
ability of other people to have sexual
freedoms and if that's the case then we
should expect these casual these
committed strategists to do all sorts of
things like oppose abortion because when
abortion is legal and free and available
and safe
more women are likely to be okay with
having casual sex they should oppose
birth control because when birth control
is available
um well there's more casual sex and it
turns out they also oppose some of these
other things like marriage equality
which they associate gay men with
promiscuity and they oppose recreational
drugs because they associate Molly and
marijuana with promiscuity
and this is statistically significant
this is a more prevalence of this in
couples that are married if they've got
kids if they've been together longer how
does that relate so usually what we'll
do is ask people there are different
ways to ask it but what's your sexual
strategy so you don't have to be married
you don't have to have kids
um but these things do all go together
um there's some really cool work by Nick
Curry and Damian Murray and colleagues
that says that so you know that that Old
Chestnut that people just get more
conservative as they age
yeah that's probably not true
um rather than just getting older and
becoming more conservative it seems like
that effect completely washes out when
you control for a number of children so
if people have kids and have more kids
they become more socially conservative
and again the idea is that the sort of
deep strategy that's socially
conservative cultures or groups or
situations make my investment in my kids
safer better for me
why would it not be the case that the
people who oppose abortion are not just
morally opposed to all of the moral
arguments that you would see around
abortion
why is that not sufficient justification
to uh wash out all of the stuff to do
with sexual competition for partners
yeah I mean it could be some people
might genuinely believe that these
fetuses are babies and they don't want
babies to be murdered
um with my colleague Jordan Moon we have
some data to suggest that that's
probably not the case
um
so if I am a person who thinks that
abortion is murder I should want to
prevent abortion right so the more I
think it's murder the more I should want
to prevent it okay so we ask people how
much they think abortion is murder for
example and we randomly assign them to
read about one of three hypothetical
bills
um all the bills would cost the same
amount of money and all of the bills
would say save the same amount of lives
but in one condition
uh the bills prevented abortions and
saved fetal lives by punishing women for
having abortions and so that's the only
condition where we also see okay if
we're going to punish women for having
abortions that should decrease the
availability of abortions and to
decrease women's engagement in casual
sex so that would be good for the
committed strategists
the other two conditions were were going
to save fetal lives by
um uh letting their be sex ed and birth
control which should decrease the need
for abortions and therefore save the
same amount of lives and the other one
is something that people often you you
probably heard this talked about We're
Gonna Save the same amount of lives but
they're newborns so we're going to give
critical care and provisioning to
newborns and save their lives they die
without this care and provisioning
so if I think that abortion is murder
and I'm just about saving lives then the
more that I'm about saving lives the
more I think abortion is murder the more
I should support all three of these
and that's not even close to what we
find
um so the more that I think abortion is
murder the more that I want to punish
women for having abortions
um but we actually see slight negative
slopes for the other two the more that I
believe abortion is murder and want to
save innocent lives
the less that I'm willing to support a
bill that would give critical care and
provisioning to needy infants
so that that probably suggests that
what they're saying is driving their
behavior is not driving their behavior
which is not surprising that happens for
plenty of people how do you know that
that's not just retributive Justice that
they feel should be duly done against
someone that has transgressed some moral
boundary
so it's possible that you know they feel
like they should punish women because
these women are transgressing
um but if they're saying that it's not
about punishing women it's about saving
lives then they should probably want to
save lives even if they don't get to
punish women for having abortions while
doing it and that's just not what we see
in the data and some other data oh sorry
just that I was thinking about the fact
that what you've tried to do there with
the three different bills is have the
same number of human lives baby human
lives
saved or protected
and what you've controlled for is
whether or not the mothers are
disincentivized from having casual sex
as openly
yeah so that that's only the one
condition that disincentivizes casual
sex the other two
um save the same amount of lives so it's
the same amount of justice so to speak
but they don't feel
the same toward those
um so I I mean there are plenty of
things going on and there are probably
some people that really do believe that
this is just their moral obligation
um I don't know those people I wouldn't
want to be interested in knowing those
people they're probably really boring
people but very nice people yeah I think
I think that it's interesting to
to consider why we have the motivations
that we do like are my stated
preferences and my revealed preferences
like are they actually what I say that
they are and how blind am I to that I
think that the abortion debate
um
a lot of the language it's surprising to
me to find that out because so much of
the language is around
the morality of it some sort of uh
ethical Line in the Sand that should not
be crossed so on and so forth
um that to me feels like
but I mean who's going to put the hand
up and say actually what I'm trying to
do is restrict sexual Norms so that so
that all of the other women and men but
I suppose there must be an equivalent
for this as well didn't you find out
that um is it
men invest more money
in their children in in like in
fathering their children like sexually
restricted men spend more money on on
their kids
so I didn't do that if if that is out
there that's probably Nick Curry and
colleagues would be my guess
um and I wouldn't be surprised if that's
true I do think that that's true
um but I think exactly what you're
saying so
I can say it's a moral goal a moral
imperative and that's a much more
convincing argument for me to say than
saying I just want to further my sexual
strategy these free love New Age hippies
be damned right
and it also requires so that for that
latter thing to happen I just want to
further my sexual strategy
it probably requires they have a PhD and
psychology and have been studying this
and realize that there's this notion of
reproductive morality a reproductive
religiosity and that things like sexual
strategy lead to religion rather than
religion leading to sexual strategy what
do you mean that
so I mean it's obviously we haven't you
know randomly assigned people to
conditions here but it does seem like
the things that religions want
um serve people who have committed
sexual strategies so have one mate have
one mate early invest really heavily in
that person stay together forever and
don't get divorced or you'll go to hell
so all of those things that religions
often support are restricted strategy
benefits
and if that's the case then you might
very well imagine people who have
restricted strategies would be attracted
to religion and so it could be that not
totally dissimilar to venting saying
well this is a religious
thing this is a moral imperative is
cover for people who just really want to
pursue their own Fitness interests at
the cost of other people's of course
nobody's saying they realize this right
they don't have access to this knowledge
it's not being done consciously they're
not just trying to screw any other
people
we're trying to screw no one
um so I couldn't help it I couldn't help
it but yeah some of the data do seem to
suggest that as people enter periods of
being more sexually restricted they're
more likely to adhere to religion and
when they leave those periods they're
more likely to leave religion so think
about going to college right so
religiosity increases when you're in a
committed relationship and decreases if
you get out of it
yeah yeah I mean there there are some
pretty cool data to suggest that the
arrow doesn't just go one way from
religion telling you what sexual
strategy to have but people who have a
certain sexual strategy get attracted to
religion because it it benefits the
strategy that they have
how should people
deal with the discomfort of hearing that
uh you would say their view on abortion
or their sense of connection between
themselves and their religion could be
their evolutionary programming coming
out in a uh how would you say the Press
Secretary of their mind giving them a
very culpable excuse like how should
they deal with that because that's
something that's like incredibly
uncomfortable to hear
yeah I mean what isn't these days I I
don't know I I'm not I'm not the most
sensitive person Chris so I would just
say suck it up
um uh I I really
there's probably a nicer way to put it
um
I don't have the capacity or bandwidth
or
natural disposition to figure out what
the heck the nice way is so suck it up
yeah do you not find as you learn more
about your evolutionary predisposition
though and the different motivations
that are coming out in your behavior
have you not found yourself in a sort of
an uncanny valley of of feeling like
you're just at the mercy of whatever
genes were given to you from a three
billion year like evolutionary unbroken
stream
I mean would I love to remake the world
in an image where everybody thought like
lizzo was the hottest [ __ ] ever which
many people do and she really probably
is yeah I mean I would love that that
would benefit me
um because she and I are shaped very
similarly for anyone who can't see what
I look like
so that would be awesome but that's just
not the world that we live in and I
think understanding reality is great and
I think acknowledging the fact that we
have
um
a lot of personal choices that that we
can make that aren't necessarily making
us slaves to some innate programming our
behavior is hugely flexible
um I I think we have to realize that too
so I I don't think we're just you know
sort of these lovely program robots that
just say you know she's hot I must mate
um I think there's a lot more to us than
that and the the messiness and the
complexity
and the that part is what I love about
humans very few of them but the ones I
like
talk to me about the relationship
between casual sex and self-esteem
because I know that you've done a ton of
work on this as well yeah
um so
I mean this is one of those things where
I don't know why people haven't gone
after this effect before but we knew in
media
um books films at the have you seen
Arrested Development no
um it's an amazing show it's hilarious
and ridiculous but in the show they have
a sort of a cheeky analog of the Girls
Gone Wild video series and it's called
girls with low self-esteem
um and so we've we have this
it's so prevalent the idea that women
who have casual sex must have low
self-esteem it's so prevalent in society
that it can be a punch line on a popular
TV series or largely unpopular TV series
but nevertheless was funny
um and so what we did was simply
investigate this and see if it was the
case for men as well and what we find is
in in America people think that women
but not men who have casual sex must
have low self-esteem and you know
self-esteem
can be hugely important for oneself but
perceptions of other people's
self-esteem are perhaps even more
important
um so if I perceive you to have low
self-esteem I'm less likely to want to
be your friend I am less likely to ask
you for a date I am less likely to hire
you for a job and I am less likely to
vote you into political office
so this isn't just you know oh whoa is
this poor sad little woman that has low
self-esteem these have real serious
economic and social consequences how are
you defining self-esteem what does it
mean
so uh feeling good about yourself very
simple classic definition a sense of
respect for yourself
okay
why is there a presumption
that casual sex somebody that has lots
of casual sex would be low in
self-esteem
so that women have casual sex who so
there's this presumption for women we
see it repeatedly
um part of it not all of it but part of
it seems to be that people presume that
women who do have casual sex are sort of
making the best of a bad job so they
presume that women would ideally prefer
to have one long-term mate who loves
them and they love and that's that and
so women who have casual sex are sort of
just
tossed into doing this they have to do
it to get by or they have to do it
because they're trying to find a partner
um
so that's part of the thinking
underlying it but I say part because
even when we tell our participants this
woman is having casual sex and she
[ __ ] loves it she is so happy doing
this she doesn't want to be tied down
she doesn't want this other stuff they
still believe that she has lower
self-esteem than a woman who has
committed sex
um so one partner and is unhappy
pursuing it so this is a really robust
phenomenon we couldn't make it go away
hopefully other researchers continue
down this line and can figure out how to
do that but
would the Assumption not be because
it is easier for women to get sex than
it is for men to get sex and that there
is a presumed uh preference for women to
get into a long-term committed
relationship so by her having sex that
is her filling some sort of void inside
that she can't uh fill with a a
long-term monogamous partner
and that that might be it they they
think that yes it's easier for women to
have sex and so women might have an
easier time attracting a mate than a man
does I'm sure you and will Costello can
talk about this and the incel phenomenon
or maybe the Femme self phenomenon all
day
um but even so
um when that woman is having casual sex
and just enjoying it she's issuing the
the strategy that people assume that she
has even when we say well she's enjoying
it people don't believe that she's
enjoying it and that that really might
be the sort of deep logic of of
presuming that women are less likely to
enjoy or seek out more partners and more
variety why do you think that men and
why do you think that women would hold
that view about other women
uh probably the same thing so I don't
think that men and women differ in their
perceptions and stereotypes there I
think the sort of meta thinking for both
is the same that well she just can't get
what she'd really like which is a single
partner why would it not be the case
that women would want to lower the
perceived self-esteem of The Other Woman
in order to make her less of a you've
already said less likely to be asked out
on a date less likely to be friends that
woman would be more of a sexual
potential sexual rival so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to lower her
perceived self-esteem in order like this
cartel this unspoken cartel between
everybody on the planet to do that but I
I couldn't see why there would be the
same motivation for men to do that
yeah so so I should um clarify that what
we're looking at here are the
stereotypes and not the reality so women
and men perceive women who have casual
sex to have lower self-esteem the
reality
isn't that
um what's amazing is that so our same
participants males and females who
report holding the stereotype that women
who have casual sex have low self-esteem
are participants who hold this
stereotype report their sexual behavior
and they report their own self-esteem
and in the participants who hold the
stereotype there is no consistent
relationship between their sexual
behavior and their self-esteem
so if there is any real world
relationship between men's or women's
sexual behavior and self-esteem it's
it's probably complicated somebody like
um I'm probably going to butcher her
name but zone of rangalova would suggest
that if you want to have casual sex and
you're having casual sex then you'd have
high self-esteem
and that that makes sense from a sort of
nice evolutionary perspective on
self-esteem as a sociometer telling you
how well you're doing in the world so I
want the same
so Mark Leary has this really great idea
that
self-esteem is really just our sort of
cue to ourselves of how well we're doing
so it's an aggregate of do I have good
friends do people support me am I
getting the sex that I want all right I
feel pretty good about myself
um so I'm I'm pursuing the Adaptive
goals that I have and I'm doing pretty
well and low self-esteem would be I'm
not pursuing these goals and I'm not
doing very well and so a sociometer
perspective would suggest them that if I
want to have casual sex and I'm having
casual sex then yeah I should feel
pretty great because I'm doing what I
want to be doing interesting and people
didn't use the theory of mind that they
had about themselves you said that when
you studied the participants that held
those stereotypes they didn't have any
correlation between their sexual
strategy and their level of self-esteem
but they hadn't decided to use their own
theory of Mind of their own experience
to extrapolate out to other people
exactly that's what's so wild about it
that it's it exists it's persistent it's
robust and it's [ __ ] wrong
it's it's kind of wild yeah yeah there
does have to be something else going on
all right well what have you got coming
up next like what's on the research
docket for you soon
dude I live in Oklahoma so all I do is
research we could talk about what I have
next for a long time
um hopefully it'll be going to
Philadelphia y equals y
um so uh
one of the things that I'm really
excited about is sort of understanding
how the mind Aggregates
um and calculates what it means to be a
good friend
um so what we're hoping to do across 30
Nations or 30 locations including small
scale societies by collaborating with
anthropologists and industrialized
societies collaborating with other
people at other universities is to
explore
what we think makes a good friend
um and we're gonna do a really simple
experiment that I kind of love so
okay who's a better friend in your
opinion Chris a friend who helps you and
helps somebody you don't like
or a friend who helps you and doesn't
help somebody you don't like in fact I
should say who's a more helpful friend
okay so the more helpful friend
would be
the first one the better friend the
petty child in me says the second one
so I mean that's the there's the sort of
objectivist view right that you're
taking which is a person who helps two
people is twice as helpful as a person
who helps just one
um and there's a view so most work in
Social psych just focuses on the two
people in the Friendship not the ways
that other people can bear on the two
people in the friendship and so on that
view however my friend behaves toward me
that should be all that I care about so
if they help me they're 100 out of 100
on helpful if they don't help me they're
zero out of zero
and our view is that people do think of
the world in terms of how is my friend
going to radiate positive effects on me
both directly by helping me but also
indirectly by [ __ ] my enemies or at
least not helping them
and so what we predicted and find is
that at least in the U.S
people view friends is super helpful
when they help me but not my enemy they
view them as much less helpful if they
help both of us which is basically
saying I view objectively more helpful
friends is less helpful
and they view friends as very unhelpful
obviously if they only help my enemy and
not me
that's fascinating
fingers crossed we do it across cultures
and find something pretty interesting
it's it's possible that all sorts of
culture and ecology could be affecting
people's inputs to this but I think the
the overall effect is going to be robust
and I do think it it starts to tell us
that
when we say somebody is nice we mean
they're nice to us and when we say
somebody is a glorious monster we mean
they're a glorious monster for us yes
yeah I wonder whether they'll be uh sort
of a sex ratio hypothesis of the number
of enemies versus friends that you have
in the local environment and if you were
surrounded by more enemies than you were
friends the relative amount of
investment that your friends gave you
would be more or less valuable
yeah so there's some really cool stuff
on relational Mobility so how able we
are to get in new friendships and leave
old friendships and so you can imagine
that in a similar way if we sort of have
to be friends with our enemies
um there are different costs and
benefits of of how our friends then
treat those enemies uh yeah maybe
ideally if if you were in a an
environment where you were overrun by
enemies you would have to collaborate
with them at some point so perhaps you
would perhaps you would be prepared to
put up with more uh shallow displays of
friendship from your friends and then
maybe there would be a change in terms
of the amount of venting that you would
do behind the scenes in order to make
sure that oh we're actually still I know
that you're kind of pretending to be
friends with them but it's like it's
still really us that are the proper
friends on the other side of that yeah
it is so interesting that the the knobs
and dials and faders that you think
about with regards to people's
friendships what they do for other
people their level of disclosure within
their own friends that level of personal
vulnerability what it is that they tell
them how much venting they do how much
sabotage they do with other people like
when you add all of this together a
it's not surprising that friendships are
such complicated things to try and
manage
yes we don't we don't talk about that
nearly enough I mean you had Denver on
he said that having friends is the next
best thing for your health behind
quitting smoking right and lacking
friends this is some Holt Lund stat work
is equivalent or at least being lonely
to smoking 15 cigarettes a day
so maybe we should pay as much attention
to our friendships as we do about you
know where our genitals go I
uh increasingly now and it's like
whatever 550 episodes into the show
every single happiness researcher that I
bring on Laura Van de cam cassia Holmes
like whoever it is that I speak to that
has dedicated their entire life to
studying happiness I it's almost boring
to ask like you know what are the habits
of the most happy people that you've
studied and they go oh well you know
they've got good relationships the first
thing always comes up they've got good
relationships and then Downstream from
that maybe it's to do with a sense of
belonging to a community friendships
again maybe it's religiosity and that
they have like people that are religious
seem to live longer well that's a sense
of community again like they you know
they play team sports what the [ __ ]
that like all of these things like so
many of the things just come back to
having friendships and having a
community so yeah the reason I think
that friendship gets a bit of a
bad rap in the personal development
slash applied pop psychology like the
not progressives like like advanced
stuff this sort of low level I can't
wait to hear this well I think the
reason for it is that it's very
difficult to optimize for I think that
the current world of personal
self-development sees the individual as
Sovereign and it's very difficult to
sell somebody a course or sell somebody
a book where the answer isn't something
that you can go away go away and do
yourself so it's it's it seems like a
much more wiggly line between where you
are and the outcome that you want to get
now if you were to write a book about
how to make friends as an adult like the
outcome would be uh an externality of
you following whatever the strategy is
that's in the book but if you're to
write a book about happiness it's like
these are the things that you should do
for happiness and you go okay friends
are really important right well there's
10 books there now I need a 10 book
volume on how friendship works and what
to do and who all that sort of stuff I I
just think that
on the internet in personal development
in personal growth generally there is a
huge blind spot like friendship is is
spoken of as a big thing that needs to
be looked up looked after and then never
really applied and I think it's just
because it's hard to do
I mean a lot of people don't realize how
hard it is and so if you think about we
say friendship like do friendship but
friendship is an umbrella term for about
60 different challenges right so you
have to figure out what you want in a
friend find friends attract friends make
friends keep friends
um and then you do lose friends and you
have to deal with losing friends so you
have to navigate all of these challenges
to Simply have these medium to long-term
communal bonds and none of them are
necessarily easy
we've mostly studied them in terms of
what I need to do to make that friend
like me but we haven't thought about the
fact that the child so we've we've cast
these challenges as dyadic challenges
but we haven't thought about the fact
that okay we've evolved in these small
densely interconnected groups where my
friends inevitably and frequently
interact with people who aren't me and
these interactions that my friend has
with other people they're going to
affect my friend they're going to affect
my friendship and they're going to
affect ultimately me and the benefits
that I get out of the thing and so if
we're thinking about only dyadic
challenges we're not even recognizing
the true Rich complexity and the fact
that friendships also have super dyadic
challenges and that's that's part of
what my my work will hopefully address
but we just don't talk about it we don't
realize it only in the last like
two three years have I looked at um
so you're going to know exactly my
political leanings as I tell you the New
York Times and the Atlantic
um I read them a lot and only recently
they have come out with papers like okay
friendship is hard thank you uh mother
is new mothers especially have a hard
time making friends well yes and we
should probably look into that if social
support helps women's infants live but
halfway no
um oh it's hard to make friends in your
30s it's hard to make friends when you
move it's hard to keep friends we should
try and be better friends and it's like
no [ __ ] people
um sorry I get really excited about this
I'm I'm gonna you know do a little woo
saw and calm down but
friendship is hard and I don't think it
has to be that hard
um we have really good theories of
friendship that can tell you what to do
to get people to invest in you and have
a stake in your continued welfare and if
they do then you get those benefits of
quitting smoking
there's the book to write there's the
book that we need Jamie yeah just get me
out of teaching and I'll do it Fantastic
look let's bring this one home Jamie
crumbs ladies and gentlemen if people
want to check out the stuff that you do
online where should they go yes uh
kremeslab.com
k-r-e-m is Mary S's and Sam or they can
uh Google me and go to my Twitter
um or uh hopefully find me at a Phillies
game when they win the World Series
thanks Jamie thank you what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace
me
ant